bonjour et bienvenue pour ce live for
scènes sont ici à lyon est sûr
j'aimerais vous parler aujourd'hui c'est
le fait que guy rationalité n'est pas
cause majeure
ce n'est qu'un symptôme et je pense que
c'est une idée qui est très importante à
comprendre quand on veut combattre
laurie l'irrationalité bien sûr compte
qu'en fait ces paliers rationalité qu'il
faut combattre
c'est quelque chose de plus fondamental
voici pour preuve le bouquin de jonathan
wright alors ses idées en fait c'est
quelque chose dont on a déjà pas mal
parler sur scène ce forum notamment dans
les épisodes sur la démocratie disent
notamment où on a bien vu que la manière
la plus naturelle de parler et c'est une
ovation
c'est d'avoir d'abord une intuition et
puis de chercher ensuite à la défendre
de faire de notre raison l'avocat de
notre intuition
ça c'est vraiment l'idée fondamentale du
livre de jonathan wright est ce qu'on
appelle aussi la rationalisation et
c'est vraiment notre mode de pensée par
défaut en général on m'a d'abord une
intuition et après on cherche à la
défendre et il ya des façons d'expliquer
cela mais de façon générale ça vient du
fait que quand on cherche à défendre nos
positions d'une certaine manière on
cherche aussi à défendre notre statut ou
les la supériorité de nos valeurs
morales et éthiques
tout ce qu'on veut et du coup en fait on
est a immédiatement en position de te
défendre non seulement notre identité
mais en fait ce qui est encore pire
après notamment ce podcast d'eau de jus
la galette ou l'interview de
gestionnaires du du seul vrai dit kane
reviews en fait ce qui est encore pire
c'est parce qu'on cherche à défendre non
pas nous non pas notre identité en moi
que c'est le pire c'est lorsqu'on
cherche à défendre notre groupe social
et ce phénomène de groupe isme de
défense du groupe du lionisme comme je
l'appelle dans cette vidéo c'est
vraiment ça qui nous pousse la
l'irrationalité et qui est la cause et
l'irrationalité cela l'irrationalité
n'est pas une cause vraiment ce n'est
pas la cause de pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
vont pondre des trucs bizarres
la vraie cause c'est quelque chose de
plus fondamental qui vient de cet
organisme notre envie de défendre nos
valeurs
qui identifie le groupe notamment et
comme on l'a vu dans l'épisode 11 en
fait toute la structure de nos sociétés
notamment le fait que lorsque dit
quelque chose quand tu es la politique
est bien ce que l'on dit pas davantage
servir notre ségo nalinnes d'autres
envois du signal de notre appartenance
au groupe est très peu les conséquences
parce que chaque voix dans un vote
démocratique a très peu d'influencé
donc quand on peut ne pas se sentir
responsable des conséquences sociétales
de nos opinions critiques et ont cela en
fait on est rationnellement
irrationnelle c'est à dire qu'il est
rationnel de ne pas s'informer de ne pas
chercher à comprendre les choses juste
de faire du cycle nalinnes c'est sa
stratégie optimale d'une certaine
manière et pour faire du cinéma ligne de
la meilleure façon qui soit en fait il
est utile de faire preuve de beaucoup
d'irrationalité en cela par une fois les
rationalités n'est qu'un symptôme
ce n'est pas une cause majeure ce n'est
pas une pathologie ça c'est une
conséquence assez importante sur la
manière dont il faut combattre au body
rationalité en gros combattre
l'irrationalité en disant qu'il ya
rationalité irrationnelle ou en essayant
de proposer des arguments rationnels
pour combattre cette irrationalité
c'est un petit peu comme soigné une
fièvre en mettant de la glace sur le
fond c'est quelque chose qui peut
soulager qui peut aider mais ça soigne
pas vraiment le du noeud du problème et
l'irrationalité ils risquent de
ressurgir aussi rapidement qu'elle est
venue
or comme vous l'imaginez trouver des
arguments irrationnels pour défendre une
position c'est extrêmement facile qui
soit parce que j'arrivais à combattre
quelques-uns de ses arguments
irrationnels que la personne en face ne
va pas trouver d'autres arguments
irrationnels pour défendre sa position
en particulier ce que cette réflexion
suggère c'est que combattre les
arguments rationnels fait ça à pas
grand-chose parce que y en a d'autres
qui vont venir juste après je pense
qu'on a tendance à penser que
l'irrationalité c'est ce qui cause
l'hooliganisme non
appartenance à certains groupes sociaux
alors que en fait ce que disait pas
malheureux chercheur en soit c'est
plutôt l'inversé que c'est notre
hooliganisme en vie d'appartenance à
certains groupes sociaux et de montrer
notre appartenance à certains groupes
sociaux qui va causer ensuite notre
rationalité et ça c'est très important à
comprendre parce que du coup fin souvent
on a l'impression d'entendre certains
que il faut être stupide
typiquement le genre de presque
longtemps il faut être stupide pour
penser x comme si être stupide
conduisait à penser x mais c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe en général en
fait sur tous les sujets très polar
exemple très stigmatisant très jeune et
plein d'exemples en tête notamment tout
ce qui est politique idéologique
religieux ou autre en fait on pense
d'abord x on s'identifie d'abord à un
groupe social qui pour chi x est une
valeur importante ou un symbole et ce
n'est qu'ensuite qu'on va faire preuve
d'irrationalité au moment de défendre et
x ou de montrer notre appartenance à x
et ça c'est une conséquence très
importante c'est à dire que si on veut
amener quelqu'un a abandonné x ça sert à
rien de se rapprocher sont irrationnels
ou de combattre son irrationalité parce
que ce n'est qu'un symptôme la cause
profonde c'est louis yanis mpp à
l'irrationalité web du coup souvent le
diagnostic cognitif pertinence n'est pas
de dire que le problème du k1 10 du
soufre d'irrationalité sans que souvent
fait le poème c'est plus que la personne
souffre d'un désir soin de mettre en
avant son identité façonnée go soit de
mettre en avant son groupe et essayer de
défendre du coup son groupe et du plan
social de empreintes du légalisme et
tout ça c'est encore bien plus le cas
pour les hommes politiques puisque comme
on l'a vu dans l'épisode 8 les hommes
politiques cherchent à être et rester au
pouvoir et pour cela ils doivent prouver
en gros aux électeurs aux électeurs
potentiels notamment qu'ils font partie
de leur camp qui sont de leur côté du
coup un politicien a quasiment tout le
temps intérêt à faire uniquement du
cyclone a ling et à l'instar des
électeurs la stratégie optimale pour
faire du gossip qui n'aligne ça passe
par l'utilisation d'arguments
irrationnel
donc plus encore que pour les électeurs
reprochèrent un politicien d'être
irrationnels c'est vraiment comme
conseiller un malade de soigner sa
fièvre alors que ce n'est pas du tout la
pathologie majeur c'est juste une
réaction à la pathologie plus
fondamental qui est ce problème de
signalling dans tous ces cas en fait une
tant que le remède pertinent à avoir
c'est celui qui consiste à d'abord
s'auto diagnostiquer notre hooliganisme
notre désir de de nous mettre en avant
notre open de cigna line en fait c'est
bon ça c'est si l'on veut vraiment
montrer quelque chose pour iphone et ça
c'est souvent la cause de beaucoup de
gars rationalité d'après vous à faire
pour combattre cette irrationalité me
semble que c'est vraiment prendre
d'abord conscience ou aider les gens à
amener les gens à prendre conscience de
la cause vraiment delory rationalité et
pas de leur pilier rationalité en tant
que telle est la meilleure façon d'y
arriver c'est pas avoir la preuve son
talent c'est plus typiquement des
méthodes comme les questionnements à
socrate c'est de poser la question et
c'est de chercher d'amener les gens à se
poser la question des causes de l'or
appartenance à leurs groupes sociaux ou
de la repose de quoi est ce que c'est
important pro de sentir qu'ils font un
parfait qui font partie d'un groupe
social ou pourquoi est ce que c'est
important pour eux de tout montrer
qu'ils sont qui font partie du bon quant
au kiki qui sont donc elle qui pensait
être meilleur socialement je sais pas
quoi ou intellectuellement
pourquoi est ce que c'est important de
se montrer ça une fois qu'on vous qu'on
prend conscience de oui c'est ça qu'en
fait mon objectif on remplit facilement
conscience que les arguments que l'on
sort sont en fait pour aller dans ce
sens est patent pour vraiment défendre
quelque chose d'un point de vue
rationnel et une fois qu'on a fait cette
première étape d'autodiagnostic de
pourquoi est ce qu on dit ce qu'on dit
et pourquoi la question nos vraies
motivations à ce moment là on peut
passer à l'étape suivante qui pour moi
l'exception c'est pas du tout
d'apprendre la rationalité là l'étape
suivante c'est d'abord de se convaincre
que c'est super cool d'être à rationner
cessé de se motiver de trouver la
motivation de
d'aller plus loin dans la quête d'une
rationalité parce que la quête de
rationalité c'est quelque chose de très
très très très difficile et c'est ce
n'est qu'une seule fois qu'une fois
qu'on se rend compte quelques points
c'est difficile et à quel point c'est
super intéressant de chercher à être
rationnel c'est très motivant très
stimulant intellectuellement notamment à
partir du moment où on arrive à être
motivés à se dire oui c'est comme ça
qu'il faut faire à ce moment là où on
peut commencer je pense a vraiment
essayé d'attaquer le premier qu'est ce
qu'être rationnelle et c'est un très
très très difficile c'est qu'est ce
qu'un argument rationnel ccco rarement
pas si évident et notamment on va moi
j'ai un point de vue qui les traits
bayésiens je trouve que ce courant de
pensée mais vraiment le doigt sur ce qui
faut penser et c'est pas ça fait pas du
tout l'unanimité faut se rendre compte
que c'est vraiment pas facile d'être
rationnel et que c'est pas suffit pas
d'être logique de penser qu'on est
logique pour être aux logiques et
d'ailleurs pour avaliser analogique a
également beaucoup de faiblesses et aura
l'occasion d'en parler des livres à
venir et puis dans de futurs vidéo mais
avant de quoi aborder tous ces sujets je
pense que c'est utile d'abord de se
convaincre que on est très souvent dans
l'irrationalité pourquoi pas parce que
c'est notre acte mais naturellement
irrationnel non le problème c'est
quelque chose de plus profond c'est
souffrent de cette envie de sinaly
notamment montré notre appartenance
adecco et en particulier le point de
l'organisme qui je pense est vraiment un
des problèmes très très très
fondamentaux c'est pour ça que dans mes
vidéos sur ton soit démocratie et c'est
vraiment le truc c'est de combattre
c'est d'amener les gens à se rendre
compte
dans quel point on est hooligans n'est
oligan cantine dès qu'il s'agit de
sujets qui me tiennent à coeur parce qu
il ya un camp auquel on s'identifie et
parce qu'on veut défendre ce camp à tout
prix c'est ça qui à cause notre
organisme
et c'est cet organisme qui ensuite va
opposer notre irrationalité voilà
c'était une marche forcée sur ce sujet
des rationalités n'est qu'un symptôme
pas une cause j'en ai c'est à dire ce
que vous en pensez dans les commentaires